What you’re looking at right now is an optical
illusion.
While I’m talking, focus on the center,
and think about how easy it is to fool your
eyes and your brain.
Hello easily tricked simpletons, Jules here
for Dnews.
Before we begin, I’d just like you to know
that your eyes are lying to you.
Right now.
Sight is simply a perception of reality which
we assume to be true because practically,
it works.
But what you think you’re seeing is actually
reflected light waves, flipped upside down,
reversed, then converted into electrical impulses,
reinterpreted and finally projected as visual
consciousness.
This whole process takes a little less than
a tenth-of-a-second.
Now, that tenth of a second delay is way too
long.
If you’re an early ancestor hunting fish
and your fishing spear is off by a tenth of
a second, you’ll probably miss.
So to bridge the gap, and to make all of its
processing duties easier, your brain makes
predictions about where things in your field
of vision will be, and sometimes it just makes
things up all on its own.
That’s where optical illusions come in.
Optical illusions are basically hacking your
eye-to-brain connection by predicting where
your brain is likely to screw up and send
you false information.
There are effectively three types of optical
illusions: literal, physiological, and cognitive.
A literal illusion is the simplest, and can
be demonstrated in this drawing by American
illustrator Charles Allan Gilbert called All
is Vanity.
At first glance, the image appears to be of
a skull, but as your eyes adjust to the details,
it is in fact a woman sitting at her vanity
mirror.
There are no skulls in the image whatsoever,
but nearly all viewers see a skull.
Why?
Well, as I said earlier, your brain does everything
it can to bridge the tenth-of-a-second delay,
and one of these methods is by filling in
details based on pattern recognition.
In this instance, the image in front of you
has enough “skull-like” patterns that
your brain initially reads it as a skull,
which saves it the energy of processing every
shape and color and angle.
Literal illusions work by approximating a
different object or setting closely enough
to fool your brain for a moment before all
the details settle in.
The next type is a little trickier, and is
called a physiological illusion.
Take a look at this grid and try to count
the grey dots at the intersections.
What’s that?
They keep disappearing?
Gotcha!
But this illusion, which was discovered by
Ludimar Hermann in 1870 and is thus called
the “Hermann grid”, is not based on your
brain’s mistakes, but the limitations of
your retina.
Specifically, it is believed to be based on
something called “lateral inhibition”.
See, light-receiving neurons in your eye -- photoreceptors
-- are arranged in rows.
When one of them is stimulated by light, the
surrounding neurons are inhibited and respond
less strongly.
Your eye does this to filter out a lot of
light noise, keeping the most dominant neurons
brightly lit and creating contrast with less
dominant light sources.
In the Hermann grid, at the intersections,
your receptors are flooded with white light
from four sides.
This creates a lot of lateral inhibition,
and the receptors in those areas respond less
strongly, making the intersection appear darker.
But, if you look directly at any one intersection,
the grey disappears.
This is because the center of your vision
has a significantly higher concentration of
photoreceptors and creates a clearer picture
than anywhere else in your eye.
And finally, there are cognitive illusions.
These are, in my opinion, the coolest, because
they take place far away from either your
eye or the purely visual processing center
of your brain.
These illusions happen in your understanding
of the image itself and your existing knowledge
of the world.
Look at this famous staircase, known as the
Penrose stairs, which directly influenced
famous optical illusion maker, MC Escher.
The trick with both Penrose and Escher is
that the image is physically consistent with
how a staircase works, but practically impossible.
You’d be going down or up forever.
According to the father and son team which
created the staircase, "each part of the structure
is acceptable as representing a flight of
steps but the connexions are such that the
picture, as a whole, is inconsistent."
The image doesn’t make any sense while having
no actual flaws.
Your brain doesn’t know what to do with
the conflicting information, and so it accepts
a totally paradoxical image.
Gottem!
Ultimately, your brain and eyes take a lot
of shortcuts for efficiency, but at the expense
of accuracy.
And by the way, although these are the most
prevalent theories we have right now, almost
all of these explanations for optical illusions
have been challenged.
The reality is, we’re not great at figuring
out why our eyes and brains are so screwed
up.
So the next time you see something crazy,
it’s more likely that it’s your own faulty
processing system, and not a total collapse
of the universe and its functions.
What are your favorite optical illusions?